so Donald Trump is defending his
abandonment of the Kurds which we've
been following this week by pointing out
that hey the Kurds didn't help us during
World War two where were they this
actually may be one of Donald Trump's
dumbest comments so far but remember
that Trump said he was not abandoning
the Kurds that if turkey does things to
the Kurds that he doesn't like he will
obliterate their economy and yet here he
is just a day after of course turkey
immediately started bombing Kurdish
forces saying here's why it's okay for
us to abandon the Kurds let's sort of
work through it backwards here's Donald
Trump's comment during a truly bizarre
press conference yesterday
now the Kurds are fighting for the land
just so you understand they're fighting
for their land and if somebody wrote in
a very very powerful article today they
didn't help us in the Second World War
they didn't help us with no Normandy as
an example they mentioned names of
different battles they were there but
they're there to help us with their land
and that's a different thing in addition
to that we we have spent tremendous
amounts of money on helping the Kurds in
terms of ammunition in terms of weapons
in terms of money in terms of pay with
all of that being said we like the Kurds
I'm glad that all that being said we
still like them it's nice for him to
mention we still like the Kurds but I'll
go further
the Kurds didn't help us in the
Revolutionary War
the Kurds didn't jump in and help the
Union during the Civil War where have
these people been this is bizarro world
ladies and gentlemen now what is
important to understand here is that
Trump is now defending his abandonment
of the Kurds because as soon as he did
it exactly as we predicted Turkey bombed
Kurdish forces in northern Syria but
just two days ago Trump said nothing
better would happen to the Kurds or he's
going to obliterate Turkey's economy
Trump tweeting just a couple of days ago
as I have stated strongly before and
just to reiterate if turkey does
anything that I and my great and
unmatched wisdom imagine that consider
to be off-limits I will totally destroy
and obliterate the akan
of Turkey I've done before so what were
the parameters of that because saying
the hell with the Kurds they didn't help
us in World War two is not exactly what
you say before swooping in to their
defense as you promised you would just
two days ago maybe just as hilariously
by the way Trump was asked so this is an
alliance you've ruined now isn't it
going to make it difficult to make other
alliances in the future since you've
abandoned the Kurds Kurds and Trump says
nah alliances are easy the Kurds
helped the u.s. defeat Isis and by
allowing this offensive is it going to
be more difficult in future times of
need to develop alliances no it won't be
it won't be at all alliances are very
easy but you know our alliances have
taken advantage of us if you look at how
much money we spend on NATO and how much
money
countries from Europe who are really a
much bigger beneficiary than we are okay
you know this they're there and we're
here oh good okay alliances are easy so
that's not going to be a problem you
bail on the Iran nuclear deal without
Iran having done anything in violation
of that deal but somehow it's going to
be no problem getting people to trust us
in the future you bail on the Kurds and
they immediately get attacked but it's
going to keep being easy to make new
alliances because alliances are easy I'm
glad it's all going so well and that
everything is so easy right I mean how
backwards are things when the guy who
got a bogus bone spurs letter to avoid
Vietnam is criticizing people who helped
us fight Isis for not helping us in
World War two however many years ago
it's now been since that war there is
one upside to this entire turning on the
Kurds thing that I can point to it may
actually do more damage to trump with
Republican lawmakers than with anybody
else
Republican voters okay I mean many
Republican voters don't know much about
the Kurds at all and many of trumps
followers the voters themselves are
going to just defend anything that
Donald Trump does no matter what
Democratic lawmakers Democratic voters
they're already anti Trump because of
thousands of other things that Donald
Trump has already done but Republican
lawmakers I'm talking about people like
you know loony Lindsey Graham or Moscow
Mitch McConnell and others they actually
may be angry enough with Donald Trump
about his abandoning a group that has
been solidly working in conjunction with
us for our national security for many
many years that he may suffer some
political consequences but even the
opposition to what Donald Trump is doing
with the Kurds hear from people like
loonie Lindsey and Moscow Mitch may be
merely posturing in order to set
themselves up to be more credible when
it comes to saying impeaching Trump no
that's not something we have to do
subpoenas and making sure that Donald
Trump actually responds to the subpoenas
now because the entire impeachment thing
is a witch hunt anyway there's the
possibility that the opposition to Trump
from Republican circles on the Kurdish
issue may be a calculated cover to
obtain more credibility when they defend
against Donald Trump's impeachment
that's exactly what I want to talk about
next